CBS News chief Washington correspondent
Face the Nation anchor John Dickerson is
with us from Washington John good
morning good morning charlie
so where does this leave us well it
leaves us watching to see if those
Republicans who were nervous before
about a repeal only plan what they do
with this legislation that Mitch
McConnell puts forward you know they
would they started to go up this hill
six months ago Republicans did and they
got very nervous because while there had
been promises that there can be a
transition that where no one will be
hurt they not only does the CBO suggest
that can't be the case but insurance
companies which have to plan well ahead
of any promise
some day reform that might happen make
their decisions and that hurts people in
the market so we'll see if go ahead I'm
sorry well we'll see if those members of
Congress are willing to make that leap
that some day down in the future they
can create a replacement after obviously
such difficulty doing it now are they
prepared to leave 18 million Americans
or more uninsured well that's the yes
exactly that's the point in the
political calculus here of course is the
on the other side are they prepared to
not fulfill a promise that they made to
Republican voters that they would repeal
but there is a real downside challenge
and also there have been Paul Ryan at
one point said no one will be worse off
if there's a repeal that's a very very
tough promise to make of if they do just
repeal the drama of how this unfolded
last night is incredible to read just as
the president is hosting Republican
senators at the White House reportedly
saying that the party will look like
dopes if they can't pass repeal and
replace and then as the dinner breaks up
two senators who were not there put out
these statements saying the deal is dead
is it clear that McConnell even has the
votes to repeal Obamacare well that's
the that's the question is whether those
moderates and even some who might not be
considered moderates who were worried
about a repeal only because of what
would happen in this quote-unquote
transition period the notion that it can
be a stable transition is very difficult
because insurance companies make their
own decisions and and that leads to
instability how do you fix that
instability with legislation but they
can't pass legislation and so we'll have
to see who makes that decision but it is
extraordinary I mean
we should step back remember that that
President Trump not only promised health
care that where more people would be
covered they would have access to any
doctor they wanted and it would be
cheaper that was the original plan when
he came into Washington he said there
would be repeal and replace not based on
anything Mitch McConnell would do but
based on his skill he said I alone can
do it so this is a this is a blow to the
president's ability to read the
legislative landscape and he's a
marketer that's his job and this bill
even in the House version or in the
Senate version was never popular the
full power of the president's marketing
which did so much for him in the
campaign was not able to be used on this
legislation
meantime Chuck Schumer says it's time to
work together on a bipartisan health
bill John we'll see if that happens
thank you